Hãy quang xử kiến sản xuất quan bộ giống ai phương mửi bài tẻ nổ, bao gồm cả các phín bản cao khắp,
thay vì phụ thuộc và các cơ sận tại Trung Quốc như trước đây, đây là lần đầu tiên Trung lịch sử,
quan bộ sản phẩm mới của hãng, được lắp sáp bên ngoài Trung Quốc ngay từ ngày đồng giá mắt.
Giờ phân thích cho rằng, xưa thay đổi này không chỉ mặng ý nghĩa về địa li sản xuất,
mà còn phà nâng nú lực của Apple, chung việc tải có chút chối cùng ứng để thích ở người tình hình của tế nhiều biến đậu.
Vì anh chuyển sản đậu, giúp Apple tận dụng lợi thay từ chung chình máy kỳnh ín dờ,
cùng cậu đại đủ đau thứ công nghệ cao của chính phủ nước này,
khi anh tập đoàn đã phân bộ sản xuất cho năm nay, anh tệ anh đậu,
Trung đó có cơ sở của ta ta gruốc và Phosphon,
nhằm đáp ở NewCow của các thị trường trong liền như Mỹ và Chóo.
Cui để nghề đủ đánh giá là mình chính gió sản cho dụng dịch chuyển chủ et sả chị toàn cầu.
Hì anh đậu, ngay cả nội lên như Trung tâm sản xuất công nghệ mới của thế giới.